I am going to write a book I am going to
write a book in Korean the reason I'm
telling you this is it's going to be
about you it's going to be about your
story your struggle and your scar at the
end of my presentation today what I want
from you is one hour of your time and
your a commitment to have an interview
with me to pay for it and change
thousands and hundreds of humans life
and their struggle the today I am going
to share my personal story what was my
scar how it was healed and what I am
going to do about it so I believe
everyone has some sort of scar and
struggle it can be something very
personal
small being slightly overweight we're
having some sort of personal struggle
growing up my scar my struggle is two
things if you want understand my scar
you have to understand Korea where I'm
from that's the tiny country in in Asia
thankfully it's South Korea not the car
not the country that the leader is
dealing with the previous bascule play
arena so my whole life was from there
100%
I was Korean it's a very congested City
the Seoul where I'm from and this is my
life everyday going to subway and I
wanted to explore the word I want to
travel I wanted to have something more
something more adventure but that they
never happened to me and
second part I'm coming from pretty
humble background none of my family
member ever lived outside of Korea
before none of my extended family ever
explored outside of Korea
and it's me after almost 30 years of my
life in Korea first came to the GSB
that's my first time actually leaving
abroad so those two things being hundred
percent Korean coming up a little bit
from humble background was actually very
challenging coming to the GSB because
I'm surrounded by all these people that
has millions thousands of so amazing
experience they traveled all around the
world they went out there Steve the word
they went to the best company in the
world best school in the world and I'm
consistently comparing myself with them
and also it seems that they're from a
lot better background that I do and
people are spending a lot of money into
some sort of social DVDs and stuff so it
made me feel I'm not belonging here it's
very first and I struggled just taking
part how I was healed so some of you
from GSP are pretty familiar with what
this is about this is about talk the
student-generated
initiative that people are sharing their
life story once in a week it's such a
powerful moment that people are assuring
their vulnerability their scar and their
struggle throughout that my scars got
healed I'll tell you two story remember
my scar one being Korean hundred percent
to coming for a whole humble background
and Stephan Lee tipping can you sure
what's your hand yeah please my friend
from GSP and he is korean-american leap
from poor and rate in United States and
very surprisingly for me his family
didn't want
to be Korean he was born in Korean as a
Korean but he was raised edge American
he didn't grow up speaking Korean at all
mostly English didn't have didn't eat
Korean food just culturally he was
raised to American and there was one day
he went to school and there's Asian food
day there was like sushi kimchi some
soup and everyone in the school and in
that Baltimore that he was the only
single Asians around there we're looking
at him to say something
Oh Stefan it said Asian food day you
should speak up and I remember in his
talk he shared that he didn't know what
to say he just started crying crying for
days I can only feel how hard how
painful it was being not Korean not
American having that identity struggle
growing up and hearing his scar and
struggle considered like instantly
healed my scar Wow
being hundred percent Korean wasn't
actually that bad and second part me
coming from humble background so this
all [ __ ] but light on my fellows just
stress make Nina whom I'm deeply admire
her passion for social impact and her
strength to make it happen
but what I thought struck me even more
is her struggle in her background if I
understood correctly you know you're not
from any sort of really fancy background
but you some sort of head of this
destroyed strength and you had had a
struggle having some sort of social
mission in his heart in her heart but
not really fully implementing it and she
went to Rhonda in Africa and realized
her her passion but
she get her strength and her value
permission from her family her parents
dead and mom loved her and always shared
the value that Nina do the right thing
go out and and make a great and better
impact that you can make and I remember
my father my mother always gave that
same value to me too
they loved me so much they gave me
tremendous amount of things the love the
value and all that time I didn't think
about that one I was just complaining
I'm comparing myself with others and
hearing her struggle and her life story
made me realize how much I had so what
I'm going to do I told you I'm going to
write a book I'm going to write a book
of your story your struggle and your
life story and let me tell you a little
bit of Korea so how much of the
impatiens and can be as you of minor
Koreans are one of the most mobile
penetrated society they're you they're
playing game crazy hours always on the
phone but another stunning statistics
one of the high side suicide rate in
OECD high set highest working hour it's
a very intense society people have
enormous amount of stress and social
pressure and luckily I have a little bit
of presence this is a math of the people
that comes to my personal blog and the
more the read a dense color means that
they're the more people are coming so
this is just a start I can leverage
something I have and my passion and my
network to change you one of you won't
re very time to hundreds of thousands of
change of the people's life in Korea
so now it's your turn this is time you
can put up your phone serious take your
phone out please and all you need to do
is email me right now I know you're busy
your life will be crazy like sprint
outside of this time so if you feel that
you want to do it just send me an email
something at stanford.edu I'm in and I
will follow with you to schedule the
time and having your life story I know
every one of you has a fascinating life
that's why you're here
but I also know that you have struggle
you have scar and you are amazing human
being that challenge don't give up deal
with it and go out and try to change the
word and you sharing that story can go
far away I believe that's the GSP all
about and that's isn't it that what and
who you are all about thank you